your knees are weak your stomach's in
knots and you can't stop thinking about
someone yep you're in love or you think
you are but what's actually happening in
your body
well you're not imagining it whether
it's love crush or lust a whole bunch of
hormones neurotransmitters and other
body chemicals are shifting into high
gear
first up is dopamine that's right the
pleasure chemical more often associated
with drug use gambling or any
pleasurable activity goes up when you're
in love whether you've been together
just a short time or you're in a
long-term relationship that means it
feels good when you see that person and
you want to see them more what about the
butterflies I think I might be sick
feeling you get around your crush if you
have sweaty palms and stammer whenever
you're together you can think of a few
body chemicals one is a stress hormone
cortisol which can constrict the blood
vessels in your stomach and give you
that butterflies feeling others like
adrenaline and norepinephrine can make
you feel energized and excited to be
with the one you love boosting your
heart rate while at the same time
causing you to have dry mouth and fumble
your words maybe the most important of
all is oxytocin also known as the love
hormone it's a powerful force in the
human body playing a key role in social
interactions and health parents bond
with babies and new mothers produce milk
it also comes into play during orgasms
feeling empathy for other people sex
when you hug or kiss oxytocin goes up
bringing you closer to your mate some
other cool things happen to your body
when you're in love for example
testosterone can go up in women but drop
in men this reaction like the stuttering
thundering heartbeat and sweaty palms
may fade as you get to know a person
thankfully but the good news is that a
lot of those feel-good chemicals like
dopamine and oxytocin are still around
in long-term relationships so while you
may be over your honeymoon phase the
lovey-dovey feelings can still get you
[Music]